emergencia climática en varias partes
del mundo Fuertes lluvias azotaron una
comunidad del Norte de California
Estados Unidos más de 1500 personas
fueron evacuadas debido al colapso de un
dique 50 estadounidenses fueron
rescatados este sábado estas lluvias
llegan después de intensas Nevadas que
también afectaron a los habitantes de
ese territorio más al sur Perú se ha
visto fuertemente afectado por los
embates del ciclón el gobierno declaró
el estado de emergencia en siete
regiones cientos de familias han sido
desplazadas lo que se espera en Lima en
los próximos días de acuerdo a lo que ha
dicho la comunidad científica es de que
el ciclón conocido como yaku está
descendiendo de la zona norte y está
incrementando la temperatura de las
aguas y eso puede provocar lluvias en la
zona costera de Lima mientras en
Argentina se vive la peor ola de calor
en cinco décadas según el servicio
meteorológico nacional el país austral
registró además el segundo febrero Seco
de su historia el promedio de lluvias
descendió a un 49% en realidad el calor
afecta a la gente Modesta gente Modesta
sufren calor sufre el calor hay
deshidratación ahí sobre todo la gente
de
pocos recursos y sobre todo los niños
hay muchos problemas de deshidratación
con los niños especialistas del Centro
Meteorológico Nacional señalan a la
crisis climática como una de las
causantes de estos trastornos del tiempo
tal fenómeno hace que la probabilidad de
ocurrencia de olas de calor prolongadas
aumenten en un 60%